Ми пішли на штурм пів на восьму ранку.
І доволі непогано тримали позицію. Але, на жаль, ми йшли типу,
як на "чмобіків", на мобілізованих.  А пішли на вагнерівських,
морську піхоту "Вагнера".
27-річний Антон отримав поранення в бою під Бахмутом.
В окоп, де він перебував, прилетіла ворожа граната, а потім - міна.
Залишився живим на тих позиціях тільки я і "Мирон",
Анатолій Мироненко, того, якого я перев'язував, штурмовика єдиного,
ми змогли врятуватися, слава Богу.
На лікуванні Антона підтримує кохана Юлія.
Через серйозне осколкове поранення побутові справи даються
йому нелегко. Білі цятки, котрі видно на рентгенівських знімках,
- це уламки ворожих снарядів, якими всіяне тіло хлопця.
Тут трьох пальців цих немає тут. Тут розламана кістка.
Там відломлений, відірваний палець.  Я весь всипаний осколками.
Тут в мене був отвір від осколка. Ось тут 16 сантиметрів.
Після травм і операцій Антону складно одягатися.
Утім йому в нагоді став адаптивний або ж "кіберодяг".
Він має розріз з одного боку, скріплюється липучками й зав'язками.
Я взагалі  не міг би носити ані футболок, ані нічого абсолютно.
Апарат Ілізарова був, шпиці стирчали.
І я на одну сторону одягав, а тоді  раз мені передню і задню частину
звели тут і позліплювали. І все. І я одягаю просто через праву руку.
І тут мені скріпляються і підв'язують. І ось тут теж бік повністю все на липучках.
"Кіберодяг" розробили у цій майстерні у Дніпрі.
Це футболки, сорочки, шорти, труси, кофти.
Він розстібається, і поранений захисник може перевдягнутися,
не підіймаючи руки. Ця рука, наприклад, може бути пораненою,
може бути ампутованою, може бути в гіпсі.
Марина шила одяг для військових ще з 2014 року.
З Ксенією вони познайомилися на курсах крою та шиття.
А з початком повномасштабного вторгнення дівчата почали
волонтерити разом. Вони об'єднали 500 волонтерок у спільноту "Швейна рота".
Ми розуміємо, що вдвох ми багато не пошиємо.
І тут Ксенія дає таку ідею, каже, а зробімо спільний пошив.
Я говорю, як це так, спільний пошив? Вона каже, а давай ми залучимо
з різних міст дівчат і ми всі разом щось пошиємо.
Даємо об'яву: "Дівчата, об'єднуйтесь з нами, допомагайте".
І є відгук. Перші там, по-моєму, 15 майстринь написали нам
з різних куточків України. Саме ці дівчата зараз є головними в наших підрозділах.
Марина, Ксенія й інші волонтерки у Дніпрі готують лекала,
закуповують матеріали, роблять викрійки й формують
набори для майстринь-волонтерок.
Наш набір, який ми надсилаємо нашим майстриням,
які нам допомагають. Вони отримують такий пакунок і шиють.
Коли одяг готовий, вони зв'язуються з нами і відправляють, куди треба.
Волонтерки "Швейної роти" - це жінки, які живуть в Україні і в Європі.
Вони виготовляють одяг вдома, а потім надсилають
у шпиталі або індивідуально військовим. Усе працює завдяки донатам.
У нас є форма для запитів, і нам пишуть, відмічають:
потрібно 50 футболок,  50 трусів,  50 шортів, і ми по всім
нашим майстриням, у кого готово, спрямовуємо туди.
І так забезпечуємо госпіталі. І є ще адресна  форма доставки до захисника,
якщо захисник один,  або їх може декілька бути в палаті.
Вони побачили  інформацію при нас,  і заповнили цю форму,
відмінили, що їм потрібно,  і ми спеціально для них зібрали.
За рік "Швейна рота" виготовила понад 25 тисяч виробів.
Волонтерки певні: кожен, хто вміє шити, може допомогти.
Ми приїжджаємо в госпіталь і бачимо, як хлопці деякі,
в кого ще немає "кіберодягу", як вони прикриваються ковдрами,
прикриваються покривалами, і щоб хоча б вийти на вулицю,
погуляти, я хочу, щоб вони всі могли це зробити.
Мене мотивує дуже велика вдячність хлопцям, які зараз стоять за нас…
В Антона вже кілька комплектів "кіберодягу".
Завдяки ним він може самостійно вдягатися й ходити
на прогулянки чи до лікаря.
Це моя любов, улюблена футболочка. Ця ще краща. Вона без котів.
У лікарні хлопець проведе ще щонайменше два місяці.
Після виписки свій "кіберодяг" він хоче залишити іншим військовим.
Адже потреба в ньому не меншає.